Are humans the only animals
that enjoy a nice drink
after a hard day's work?
Nuh-uh-uh!
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey, everyone.
Laci Green here for DNews.
There comes a time
in everyone's life
when we ask ourselves, wait a
minute, do animals get drunk?
This is usually asked
when we are drunk
and possibly watching
viral videos on YouTube,
like the classic video of
this little square that
got a little to
hammered snacking
on fermented pumpkins that
were left outside these folks'
house for Halloween.
I die pretty much every
time I watch that one.
Just like humans,
animals can get drunk.
And some species actively pursue
intoxication out in the wild.
Of course, these animals aren't
hitting the local rain forest
fridge to crack
open a can of beer.
They're hitting the
fermented fruit.
Fermented nectars,
pumpkins, and berries
all contain small
amounts of alcohol,
which is perfect if
you're a small creature.
And smaller creatures
are the ones
usually getting drunk
because it doesn't
take as much to do them in.
Take, for instance, the
tiny pen-tailed tree shrew
which loves to sit the
nectar of the bertam palm
in the Malaysian rainforest.
Thanks to its own
production of yeast,
the bertam palm
produces fermented
nectar that's about 4% alcohol,
the same as some beers.
Animal physiologists in Germany
observed the pen-tailed tree
shrews making their way over
to the bertam palm every night,
sometimes making
two or three trips
and hanging out for a few hours.
And the tree shrews
aren't alone.
Tumblr's favorite,
the low loris,
also enjoy a nightly
brew in the rainforest.
But even though these
guys love to drink,
the animal kingdom's real
alcoholics are vervet monkeys.
Vervet monkeys
have the same rates
of alcohol consumption in
their colonies as humans do.
Most of the monkey's
drinks some.
12% drink heavily.
5% drink excessively, and a
small group don't drink at all.
In this species,
the monkey youth
also tend to drink more
than the grown-up monkeys.
Sounds familiar?
It's all coming together now.
These mischievous little
fur balls are cray-cray.
The ones that live in
the Caribbean islands
are known for snagging
alcoholic drinks
from tourists
lounging on the beach.
In the past, they were
known for gorging themselves
on fermented sugar
cane crops being
grown by the rum industry.
Now, hop on over to
Australia, and Darwin locals
are about to experience an
annual phenomenon dubbed
drunk lorikeet season.
And around October or
November, hundreds of lorikeets
exhibit tell-tale
symptoms of drunkenness.
They can be seen falling over,
having difficulty flying,
or flying into things.
They also become very
friendly with humans,
which is not typical
of lorikeets.
Scientists in the
area believe this
happens because there
are lots of fleshy,
fermenting fruit
available for the birds
to snack on in the fall.
And a similar phenomenon happens
in Vienna with the song birds.
But here's the sad part.
About half of the
drunk lorikeets
seen by vets in
Darwin, Australia die.
Just like too much
alcohol kills humans,
too much alcohol kills animals.
The lorikeets are so small,
their little bodies just
can't handle it, which FYI, is
why human peoples should never
give alcohol to animal peoples.
So there you go, DNews answering
your life-altering questions
one video at a time.
You're welcome.
Thanks for joining me guys.
We'll see you again
soon with more updates.